thank you
[Music]
do any of you guys use online betting
apps for like sports or anything I used
to
um so I just got one because my neighbor
does it every weekend uh every Sunday
and we watch football together
so yeah I get I got this St it's the BET
MGM Scandal yeah [ __ ] yeah I know all
about this oh [ __ ] what is this what
happened what happened yeah so they're
targeting Pro poker players uh through
so Global Payments is like this company
that runs all of the [ __ ] bet MGM
WSOP it's like they handle all of the
payments the way that people can deposit
money and like bet and all that stuff
but they do it it's like a third party
company that does it for wsop.com and uh
bet MGM and like all these different
sites well someone it's like specific
because they know that these poker
players have like x amount of money in
their accounts and if you ever deposited
with e-checks they're like going down a
list and basically hacking into these
people's accounts and taking like ten
thousand dollars and there's nothing
that these poker players can do about it
like so their Banks were like okay we
got you it's fraud and like they had to
file fraud reports or whatever but then
Global Payments was like hey remember
that money we stole you owe us that back
yeah and they're like so it's a whole
big [ __ ] thing right now because it's
super targeted it's like professional
poker players that have X amount of
money that have used e-checks because so
far people that use PayPal haven't had a
problem but like E-Check specifically
yeah they got access to these people's
bank accounts somehow and we're able to
like just withdraw like tens of
thousands of dollars it was a whole I'm
part of like poker Twitter like I didn't
mean to be but all of a sudden all these
poker Twitter started coming and then I
just started following people one by one
and now like my whole feed is all just
poker people like with e-checks is it
just like an electronic check that's all
it is yeah basically it's the only way
you can like do it like AC H transfer
like like if you don't want to use
PayPal I always use PayPal because I got
really scared a lot of people were
getting hit
um but it seems to be only if they knew
that you had a big win in poker so and
then and then you had to used E-Check to
deposit whoa not PayPal so I was like
because they were like if you have you
should delete your account right now if
you haven't gotten hit yet because they
pull it back from you really eradicate
your wsop.com account like start a new
one like just [ __ ] cancel all of
those accounts get a new bank account
get a new bank get a new everything get
a new card is online poker legal now
like for all states uh not for all
states it's actually federally illegal
um but in certain States it's regulated
like Nevada New Jersey a couple other
states Nevada New Jersey wsop.com
regulates but they have like a monopoly
on the regulation which is also [ __ ]
because they haven't updated their
software or anything it just sucks like
all around just sucks but so then
there's these other companies like
America's card room ignition
um like 888 there's a lot of uh other
online sites that
okay yeah uh it's unregulated oh so it's
like a Caribbean address or something
and they yeah and they use like some
loophole that's kind of like a giveaway
like it's like something I bought gift
cards type of thing like when I bought
like back then like these different
gambling sites it was gift cards yeah
and then that came in my account closet
there it it the it shows up as like I
bought something from China oh yeah see
I never made a deposit because I always
lose all my money I wouldn't know what
it's like to cash out but I remember
buying you know that person it was out
like a gift card yeah
yeah there's some loopholes I don't know
I don't know the exact legal things but
people are like well you shouldn't trust
it because it's unregulated but these
sites have been around for like 20 plus
years yeah and so they're I don't know
trust is a heavy word yeah I mean if you
but the one that's trusted is wsop.com
which is the one getting [ __ ] hacked
and they're like yeah we're not
wsop.com's like we're not gonna help you
like it's Global Payments that did it
yeah
no they did they started sending
collections after these people so now
these People's Credit Card scores are
gonna get yeah because of money that got
stolen because of their [ __ ] faulty
system that's funny because it's not the
first time the WSOP website got in
trouble for like this [ __ ] so I would
say there was a moment called like Black
Friday or something like that it's just
like when I barely got into poker it was
like 2008. it's when they just made all
the online illegal and if you had money
on that account it's just gone yeah so
if you had like 150 000 on there some
people like lost it was just gone more
than six figures
and in WSOP which is like one of the
major [ __ ] you know websites and that
one guy with the cowboy hat he was
involved in Doyle Brunson no no the
younger one with a beard any skinny
four
it was that guy it was a couple of other
guys involved in it right and then when
they became insulted there wasn't I
forgot what the news was was so old but
then it was like that's crazy how these
things keep happening and then this wso
Speedway website still stays alive yeah
it just people still want to play poker
that's the thing well they don't have no
other choice yeah they're like okay well
I want yeah I want to play poker I guess
I'll just play on this it feels like
such a modern
um Ocean's 11 type Heist like yeah like
a to date how you would do it now yeah
it's like easier get all these like uh
Pro poker players that are winning and
then just get their info and then sign
them up fake accounts for like betting
sites well something similar to like FTX
happened back then where like you
deposit your money and you play poker
right but then they take your cash and
these guys were playing poker with it or
they were investing in it or buying
houses or whatever so they're just
numbers when you made a deposit and then
so like when all of a sudden they try to
cash out they were like oh well we don't
got your cash well the one guy that's
all over the news about that Friedman or
what's his name yeah okay so he was part
of the uh one of the poker sites oh
really that went under it everyone lost
their money that's so funny it's all
connected when you're playing because
you do live streams yeah for a poker do
people see you're like like can they see
any information about you can't see any
information just my screen name okay
yeah
he's worried is what he's saying he's
wondering well that's America's card
room
um I mean they see that they see my
screen name but that's it yeah
damn do you think something like this
could happen to you
I mean definitely like any
to you I mean you can get
um not
scarred got hacked uh and someone in
Maryland was going out to eat every day
like 200 at a time like buying
McDonald's gift cards and [ __ ]
McDonald's gift cards but also like some
other like oh nobody that buys
McDonald's like no it was like a like
fine dining person has good taste yeah
credit card stuff now do you know Scott
would tell us or Todd patellas that's
the guy that uh
well yeah he was actually the first one
to speak up because like he was one of
the first people to get targeted yeah
and then he posted on a forum I can't
remember which one it was but he posted
on a forum about it kind of like
warning because see he's the one that
went the police route he didn't know
other people were getting targeted but
then when he when um so this guy uh Joe
Joseph
um Sabine yeah his name his name on
Twitter is to be we're actually we know
him I know him he posted it on Twitter
and then that's when Todd went was like
oh I didn't know it was a bigger I've
actually been been like attacking this
on the legal route let me bring all of
you in because he didn't know that it
was a widespread issue among
specifically poker players he just
thought it was like he was a one-off
this happens in real life too like my
dad worked at a casino for like 20 years
so like there are people just like going
around seeing who's like winning big or
whatever and then so like casinos half
places where he could check their money
in because you don't feel safe just take
it yeah there's just you could keep your
money in security boxes yeah like just
taking like seven Grand or eight grand
like walking it straight to the parking
lot at like 2 A.M in the morning you
know so it's like this is just a digital
version of like people like who's
winning and who's gonna walk yeah but
they got to get your in they have to
like hack your info yes somehow and then
check the E-Check thing exactly when you
won that first tournament that one that
was like [ __ ] crazy yeah how did you
guys get the money dude we got it in
cash hilarious [ __ ] bags like a
regular bags like a movie yeah you walk
to the Paris okay yeah we watched the
Paris with the backpack and they loaded
it with a hundred and [ __ ] thousand
million dollars but then did you have to
sign the IRS form and [ __ ] and then so
what do you do with the bag you just go
home I went to the bank with it straight
to the bank yeah what's the bank with
the 100 G's yeah and it was like a kind
of a CD Bank too
good we just wanted to take a picture
with the cash because they're like we
could we could write you a check I was
like nah I want to take a picture with
files that's pretty bother though
bananas dude there's no like let me
deliver it in an armored car so they
just they just give you bricks of cash
at the [ __ ] window oh God and then
we're loading it into the bag and then
they count it in front of you and we're
just and they announced that they're
like that's ten thousand twenty thousand
thirty thousand forty thousand and like
so you know it's like okay so 117 000
right and then you're like shut the [ __ ]
up yeah whisper please
like wow yeah well when I went in the
bank there was kind of a line for uh oh
my gosh and I was like nervous as [ __ ]
this [ __ ] guys like uh are you here for
a deposit or withdrawal and I was like
deposit and he was like cash or check
and I was like cash he's like how much
cash and I was like how does seven
thousand dollars and he was like excuse
me I was like 170 000 and he was like
let me in can I get a manager over here
we have to put in 117 000 yeah I know
how to do this much money oh a hundred
thousand dollars and then but while I'm
saying this this lady is having a fight
with the teller because they won't let
her with um withdraw 50 because she did
it too many times and she doesn't have
the money in her account and she's like
yelling at them and she's got colored
hair and she's she's got a cane
she's like ready to beat the freaking
window down I was like 100 000.
let me jump the line let me jump the
line please and I wasn't there for that
because I had to get in I had to go what
I had to pick up my tracksuit
from the cleaners no no I was he was
getting on a plane to JK okay so so I
was taking pictures I dropped her off I
was taking pictures of her in the car at
the airport with her holding all his
money around her head and [ __ ] yeah and
then I go to the bank right next to the
airport they give us right at the
airport and then I was like oh this is
not a good location
and I was like good luck you got this
act like you've been there before see
you later act like you've been there but
like when when they were handing you the
money at the casino yeah aren't you like
feeling like people are watching you
dude it felt like Ocean's 11. yeah yeah
so you're scanning everybody right oh
yeah I'm like looking around about this
like you're all you brought your own
backpack oh it's like a paper bag
tote bag that has a dollar sign on it
it's his big winner I don't remember
they put him in rubber bands they had
like the the bands on them that it was
like 10 000 each yeah so they don't even
they don't even go hey like for a small
amount like tip we'll have a guard walk
you out they didn't even give you that
option well the you can ask for security
always oh okay but we didn't we just
felt like we were in a bank heist movie
we felt so cool
is it pretty heavy the bag no I mean
like you know you think it'd be more but
it was like you know 10 10 packs of like
because it's ten thousand dollars oh 10
of them it's like a brick you know like
this big it's like it'll be like this
size
yeah and there's like 10 of those yeah
so it's like this hey yo oh so it's like
when the rappers hold like a fake phone
like that's like 100 yeah like I
actually oh did you take one of those
pictures yeah if you didn't I would have
been really upset that's the whole point
because my mom my mom works at a bank
and she was like why didn't they write
you a check I was like oh they asked me
if I wanted one but I was like no I want
to pick a selfie we need a photo op yeah
that's so damn so paranoid walking
through that is so [ __ ] scary yeah
that is so scary that's good for the
poker brand that's a hundred yeah that's
a hundreds
wow that's so cool it was crazy oh dude
thank God I was like I don't know when
I'll ever see a hundred thousand dollars
in cash I've never seen it before I
don't want to see it again I just wanted
to see it I wanted to see it with my
eyeballs
[Music]